you know that moment the one where
you're watching a great movie and you're
taken out of it every time a particular
actor shows up on screen a single person
can throw a whole movie out of whack
with a performance that's clearly
disconnected from everything else it
could be painful to watch but the true
test of a great movie is whether or not
it can withstand that one clunker here's
a look at some great movies that were
almost ruined by one bad performance
Pacific Rim Pacific Rim seemed like a
sure thing in Hollywood
it's basically transformers vs. Godzilla
only smarter and it had visionary
director Guillermo del Toro behind it
but there are no certainties in
Hollywood del Toro simply didn't do the
math when he decided not to cast a
bonafide movie star in the lead role
instead he brought in Sons of Anarchy
starred Charlie Hunnam hoping that he'd
rise to the occasion and be the
charismatic thoughtful and romantic
tough guy the film needed but Hunnam
didn't rise his performance is flat and
lifeless he also had zero chemistry with
co-star Rinko Kikuchi and Pacific Rim
nearly crumbled under the weight of his
blandness however the movie didn't
totally crumble it's still a lot of fun
to watch and it made a lot of money
overseas but we can only wonder how much
better it might have been if Hana
matched the rest of the energy in the
movie gangs of new york
it's really easy to blame a bad
performance on the actor who delivered
it but sometimes it's all the result of
poor casting and Cameron Diaz was
definitely wrong for Martin Scorsese's
nineteenth-century turf war drama Gangs
of New York to be fair Diaz was on a
roll at the time having scored accolades
for being John Malkovich in vanilla sky
but Gangs of New York is a very
different animal playing pickpocket
Ginny Everdeen required Diaz to dye her
hair red and Don a Scottish accent or
maybe it was Irish to be honest it's
impossible to tell and more often than
not the accent just sort of disappears
maybe we could pile in together oh I
think you're a bit rough for this sort
of game besides I work alone there's
also a fundamental disconnect between
Diaz and her character a tough-as-nails
thief Diaz never quite finds the
character's essence and it frequently
undermines the film don't tell me are
angry with me at all you through yeah
thank goodness Daniel day-lewis was
around to keep things interesting
Shakespeare and love back when
Shakespeare and love somehow bested
Saving Private Ryan to win the Oscar for
Best Picture in 1999 lots of critics
thought it was a clever and romantic
take on the life of history's most
beloved playwright but they probably
also should have mentioned how weird it
is when Ben Affleck turns up as
legendary English actor Ned Allen is my
FX performance in the film is a genuine
head scratcher we're still not sure how
director John Madden allowed him to go
with that horrible British accent pay
attention you will see how genius crits
and legend but Affleck makes things even
worse by trying to bury it under a
smarmy layer of machismo it doesn't work
and it leaves us utterly disliking a
character that should have been a lot of
fun the film is almost unwatchable when
Affleck is on screen and his presence
becomes one of those glaring
distractions that most films can't
overcome but Shakespeare at love still
works in spite of him which is something
we can't say about daredevil The
Prestige many fans of director
Christopher Nolan argue that his 2006
film The Prestige is his best work it's
got that mix of high concept and high
entertainment fare that Nolan is known
for but we'd be a little more inclined
to call it his best movie if we could go
back in time and make him recast the
role of Olivia if you're wondering why
Scarlett Johansson was hired to play a
turn-of-the-century Brit you're not
alone it's hard to believe she was no
one's first choice for the part and we
can't imagine that producers were
worried about packing big stars into
their film they already had Batman and
Wolverine in the lead roles and Rebecca
Hall Michael Caine and David Bowie to
back them up so why Johansson well that
remains a mystery all we know for sure
is that she couldn't handle the British
accent or the turn-of-the-century
dialogue she struggles so much that she
seems to forget there are other actors
in her scenes it would take more than
magic to look past scar joe's bad
performance inglorious basterds Quentin
Tarantino's Inglourious Basterds will be
remembered for a lot of reasons not only
did it rewrite history and give Adolf
Hitler the brutal ending he deserved it
also made a star out of Michael
Fassbender and brought Christoph vaults
and Oscar
but while Tarantino has always had a
knack for casting exactly the right
person in exactly the right part
and resurrecting a career or two in the
process his decision to cast Mike Meyers
as a high-ranking British officer was
one of those WTF moments we still can't
quite get over basically we have all
rotten eggs in one basket the objective
of operation Kino left the Gonski not
the cassock Myers wasn't worth the risk
the Saturday Night Live veteran has
proven he's capable of doing great
things with the right part and Tarantino
has proven he can make almost any risk
payoff but both of them missed the mark
here Meyer seems to be trying so hard to
not do Austin Powers that he ends up
just doing a watered down version of
Austin Powers his appearance in the film
even behind all that makeup
feels like a stunt got the gist Batman
Begins Christopher Nolan has clearly had
some trouble casting female roles if
Scarlett Johansson turning up in The
Prestige didn't hammer that point home
allow us to present Exhibit B Katie
Holmes and Batman Begins we're willing
to admit that her role as Bruce Wayne's
childhood sweetheart Rachael Doss isn't
exactly the most well-rounded character
rachel is probably the worst scripted
character in the entire trilogy and in
Batman Begins she is the definition of a
stock love interest in the right hands
characters like Rachel can be quite
memorable
unfortunately Holmes brought zero nuance
to the character delivered her lines
with no emotion and Rachel always seems
to dimensional that made it easy for
Nolan to recast the character for The
Dark Knight and even though Rachel isn't
the sharpest character in Nolan's
trilogy Maggie Gyllenhaal managed to do
it Holmes couldn't make Rachel seem like
a real person thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]